we've got beautiful skies out there not
able to keep a lid on these high clouds
that have been moving through but
believe me they're harmless we're not
looking for rain we're really not
looking for a lot of wind today except
along the river where we expect the
winds to be bumpier for sure those could
get up to about 35 miles an hour
laughlin bullhead city a little breezy
even up to boulder city today otherwise
in the valley northeast breezes could
get 10 15 miles an hour that's about it
we've got a lot of 50s a couple of spots
seven hills mountains edge you've
dropped into the cooler 40s
even kyle canyon is down into the
chillier 30s up in the mountains so
occasional high clouds is what we'll
look for over the next couple of days
and temperatures are going to slide
afternoon highs are going to be down
around 70 degrees that's still a little
bit above normal so we can't complain
too much something to keep a lookout for
thursday night into friday morning a
partial lunar eclipse that is visible by
all of north america so we're certainly
going to keep you posted on that give
you a look-see but it's really easy to
see it with your own two eyes outdoors
so it starts around 11 pm and goes until
about 3 a.m more cloudy skies into the
weekend though that's friday night into
saturday we'll have more clouds and
we've got a front that's right around us
kind of opening the door for cooler
temperatures as we head towards the
weekend between now and the weekend cold
air over the west and that's just
filtering in we will stay dry but
breezy winds along the river as i
mentioned so here's your wednesday low
70's that's about five degrees cooler
than yesterday with all that great
sunshine
we had mid 70's in the afternoon 76. 66
is normal and temperatures will be a
little bit closer tomorrow at 69 than
those heavier clouds friday saturday
temperatures right around 70 degrees for
the weekend next week it looks a little
cooler as we head towards thanksgiving